hey guys I'm Ryan right hello I'm Brad
the success we're gonna be looking at a
video today that's gonna be about making
fun of people like us called how to
react okay I'm in a pretty calm mood and
I'm glad I am because I feel like when
I'm energetic that's when you might get
some people who mistake it for fakeness
so I'm like alright if it's gonna be
making fun of this I only want my
emotions to be elicited from this video
I don't know well they're about to make
fun of us that's how you do it
best yeah this requires no work okay not
thinking that's acting it's reacting is
acting mmhmm yeah you say the same thing
about porn scenes hey oh and today I
will be giving you a full-fledged crash
course training demonstration one on one
simulating emulator about how to react
to videos now the key with reactions is
provoking our reaction some human beings
have this supernatural ability to
naturally develop emotions after
witnessing an event this is called a
reaction aside from these privileged
super humans the remainder of the
population has an affixed acknowledgment
of certain situations therefore being
unable to exploit this reacting
phenomenon on YouTube however it is my
job today to teach you my constituents
how to record yourself existing for
profit this is an exaggerated process so
please bear with me step one of to press
record step two of to upload there are
several different ways to placate
emotions with what emotion that it is
trying to convey we'll call them
reactions and these include but are not
limited to indifferent reaction
frivolous reaction
ha superfluous normally under any given
circumstance the difference is that
light reflects into a recording device
and streams the content via the internet
- otherwise us and privileged human
beings even you can turn on your camera
while watching this video and become a
millionaire most computers have webcams
you don't even need to spend a single
cent other than what you spend on your
computer to earn millions the most
crucial aspect and all you leave the one
that requires the most amount of talent
is to never give constructive criticism
about anything that you are watching you
need to say the most vague and abrupt
things possible to make sure that your
audience is praying watch here are some
presets that you can derive your
reactions from that was tight ok that
beat that that beat though that that
beat though I feel like there wasn't any
that was oh I just didn't get it I feel
like they couldn't have done more with
it like like you know like you know like
man dude I don't thank you watch it you
must avoid saying the following the
color correction of the frontal subject
penalty acid in the background creating
an offset where the character appeared
as if he was part of the scenery who
kept the cartoonish expression derived
from the texture
or these eliris don't mean anything
it's rhymes out of a book report there
is no substance so explaining how one
drives in the freeway or how people
underestimated and is only at the point
where wordplay meet underlying meaning
meet inspirational backstory meets rhyme
scheme meets relation to subject matter
than a line in a rap song deserves to
remain a part of the final draft never
say anything nearly as intelligent as
that happens you need to be as big and
abrupt as possible that way the next
video your playlists can forcefully
eject itself upon to the viewer without
ever having a chance to click away it's
all about revenue and whether you embed
a clue of whatever I just said to you in
your head then you will be a clever new
and better of you veterans revenue you
will earn bonus points by having a
female in your video mum grandmum cousin
girlfriend or someone who's a
combination of the four it doesn't
matter as long as they're a woman if you
have a woman in your video you will be
able to achieve greatness no sound
effects no visual effects nothing that
is appealing to the eye just a
straight-up video no cuts
nothing interesting whatsoever forget
everything I did in this video because
it's no go now you will get no abuse if
your video is appealing right any means
so if you still know how to react now
please by all means ask your doctor if
you are a robot because all human beings
react in some shape or form to content
whether it's different or beloved
reactions exist because humans exist and
if you exist that you are just as
qualified to be reactive Amos as the
next cutting givin you got to either be
handsome look funny laugh funny or buy
your subscribers but at the end of the
day reactors are normal people unless
they have other content where they show
their creative prowess and I do go
abilities they are human beings watching
the video just like you are doing right
now it's just like the presidency you
exist for more than 35 years and you
live in America for those 35 years given
that you were born here you can run the
United States of America that's all you
need to do and you're gonna have money
money can buy anything children if you
go outside and play a dollar you will
grow a money tree because nothing to be
able to eat you what so everything I
don't even make any not money or to
pirate you know pubes or strivers
disease but I'll still do anything I'm
said you know you mean it but I guess I
care subscribe for not
I love this guy yeah we do I love this
guy
I was very creative interesting like you
know like every single time I've ever
gotten together like when we were having
this reactors assemble thing with that
live stream I remember thinking I wrote
on the phone I was like why is everyone
taking this so seriously like don't you
guys realize that like this is one of
the easiest kind of YouTube videos to
make like I'm aware of that but I think
I can upload daily I'm not saying that
it doesn't take work like there's some
things that he was pointing out that I
think that I actually offer at least oh
yeah a lot of the time like on this
channel like yeah I know it's better if
we bring on a girl but this channel they
sort of expect a girl to be on the
channel now yeah you know you get to
know the girls instead yeah and
everybody is very cool and you guys like
them for their personality not only
their looks so yeah thank you thank you
very much he talks about not giving
opinions and I feel like a lot of the
time I could go into depth about like
you have what I'm naturally thinking
yeah I'll have like genuine discussions
it's almost like a talk show no way
thank you thank you sometimes I [ __ ]
around with the editing and you know
definitely it takes time to edit and you
it's like you have to have a good time
meeting it does take skill yeah he was
saying there's like no cuts and
everything and I'm like yeah like we set
up lights we have a good mic and we have
a camera a lot of you might not know
that but it's all set up he's talking
about a lot of reactors not having any
other content and I was like thinking
man we got movie reviews we have like
short films and sketches on the channel
we got spoiler talk we got movie news so
there's a lot of [ __ ] on this channel
well made me cook not to be like what I
cook this is totally gonna come across
the wrong way that is everything I've
ever thought that's why I make sure to
do other content every once in a while
to show though like hey there's actual
stuff I could do other than react to a
video and give my opinion on it and it's
some stuff I'm like yeah I totally know
that like I said like a video to put
together for me because there's like
cuts and weird text every once in a
while a video and like Tyrone does that
too so a video to cut together for me
probably takes about like in total with
every
upload takes about like an hour and a
half to two hours right if I just did it
like straight with one video so that is
time that you put in and I put up like
three videos a day usually yeah you're
not the average youtuber either you
actually put in the dedication for like
your subscribers and tending to them and
always have like interacting somehow if
it whether it be through videos you're
interacting with them like you make it a
very yeah thank you yeah
appreciate that let's play you're my
girlfriend because it gets me more views
he's really worked up to it knees still
working hard I didn't take this video
personally like one thing I was like
he's telling the truth like cuz that is
the majority of reaction channels yeah
and you know like I'm not saying like
what makes us better I'm saying this is
what makes us better in same thing like
that's why I really like Tyrone's
channel a lot because he like throws on
a lot of fun stuff every once in a while
he does like other kinds of videos every
once in a while there are times where
it's like I won't even like the video
and then I'll piss people off because
I'm not giving them the reaction that
everyone else is gonna give them you
know cuz I'm trying to just be honest
I've always told people always I don't
act like this is the hardest thing to do
I've always told people that anyone can
do what I do anyone as long as you're
honest and willing to be yourself in
front of a camera which can just take a
little bit of time yeah anyone can do it
I seriously am saying that to all you
right now anyone can do what I do
you're different though it can't just be
anybody you have to be able to kind of
elaborating on what you just said like
you have to be able to have the
personality with it yeah a likeable
person is something that attracts other
people I'm talking about just the simple
act of like what is this a reaction
entail you know like set up your camera
then film yourself honestly checking out
a trailer or some other video like how
we just did now and then I like to go
into depth about it I actually get
worried about the review part of the
video because that's when I'm like can
go into more depth about like how I
really feel about something you know
that part gets me nervous but now when I
watch this video I'm not thinking about
my because I already know like what I do
differently nowadays typing like
reaction you got like so many [ __ ]
people and there's a reason why only a
few like actually gain a good amount of
subscribers is because those are the
ones who are very genuine about it
but then there are other ones who are
like you know they're doing every tactic
that this guy's talking about and he
definitely knows what he's talking about
no yeah about it he's incredibly
intelligent and I love that he's a
youtuber and his it's great it was that
is the exact kind of guy that I would
love to collaborate with like dude I
don't find too many youtubers willing to
be that honest I wonder if he's los
angeles-based
yeah we could have a threesome he was
kind of cute I mean for like a 17 year
old yeah is it illegal well yeah if 17
we're over 18 that sucks
oh my god I can't believe I just said
that anyway guys thanks for telling me
that video is out that was really
awesome if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects you
check out Veronica's channel where she
does a lot of acoustic covers and does
vlogging right now though she has a
cover up of a new hit song what's a call
baby I forgot I really like you yeah and
I'm gonna tell you something first time
I heard that song I was like this is so
annoying and then she put it on the
guitar and I'm like that's a lot better
like bubblegum pop guilty pleasures like
Britney Spears what can I say
I got that on him okay he loves Britney
Spears you guys are you I realized the
more videos you're in with me the more I
look like a [ __ ] hmm
well you are a lot stronger than I am
you are more brave you're like my
warrior woman protector of me
um I'm Owen Wilson in Shanghai Knights
that's right
you can follow us on Facebook Instagram
and Twitter where we're trying to get
product placement by you know doing
[ __ ] getting a lot of followers I got
like an eye infection did not clear up
with clear eyes but clear eyes I think I
already did a product placement of you
but I will try one again clear eyes are
great for many things you know you might
just be really tired and groggy in the
morning clear eyes you might get baked
out of your mind clear eyes that's why
there's sold in dispensaries from what I
hear and you might vomit but you don't
want to tell your girlfriend you vomited
clear eyes clear eyes yeah and then we
had amazing sex afterwards